Wayfarer Airlines flight 515 was an important
part of the "Breaking Bad" mythology, a symbol
of the horrible consequences of Walter White's
actions.
His decision to let Jesse's girlfriend Jane
die leads to her father, an air traffic controller,
inadvertently causing a midair collision.
The crash was subtly teased with black-and-white
prologues flashing forward to the disaster
all through the second season of "Breaking
Bad."
Saul Goodman milked the Wayfarer disaster
for all it was worth, wearing a memorial ribbon
on his lapel for the remainder of the "Breaking
Bad."
In The "Better Call Saul" series finale, he's
extradited back to New Mexico from Omaha to
plead guilty to his many crimes, flying with
a U.S. Marshal — and you can tell from the
seats it's a Wayfarer flight.
Later, he enters the courtroom in a shiny
suit complete with his memorial ribbon still
pinned to the lapel.